如果我愿意的话,我一天可以拍10条视频
其实100条,也不是什么问题
如果你知道我是怎么用DI的话,你就没有再说什么了
其实我可以随时去动一个话题,可能是什么关注的,可能是什么老伙,你们问的问题
然后会打开一个眼,然后问他
比如说,你来过解释一些内容窗做
然后他解释把那个环境挖一个眼
你过解释一下,你怎么看?
然后再换一个眼,你怎么看?
所以的话,有些时候在一些AI上花一些肺用是非常非常值得,这就好像草操,有一个想法问一邦军事,对吧
过家,你怎么看呀,对吧,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀,你怎么看呀
你不会说,学书,你怎么看呀,你可能问一些智商票高的
然后你会听去各方面的既然一会意见,对吧,这就是不同的角度
然后几年你再觉得这对不同的方啊,然后问不同的AI
另外一个方法是什么呢,就是你从小开始问,比如说
我现在是一个七岁的孩子了,然后前几国解释一些内容窗做有什么意义
我为什么七岁呢,因为我们的孩子是七岁
所以我每次问多少从七岁开始,这样就很方便有时候陪他出去玩,或者孙手给他讲一下
然后呢,经济的是18岁,我是18岁的孩子,前几岁,18岁的孩子
然后你来过解释一下,有什么意义
我是一个四岁的人,你来过解释一些什么意义,有什么意义,我这个八岁到太太,你过解释一下,对吧
我是一个博士后,你过来过解释一下
这样的话,你会发现他更容易让你第一切失务的鼎层
然后也在不同场景下的应用
所以刚才你立体会到了吗
在今天的后来往时代或者是AI是在获取信息根本不是问题,就信息的获取不是问题
什么样的信息
才很重要
就像我之前房暂负贡的点说的,忙着说的就话
制服的话很简单,就是你发现什么东西是有的,然后反复什么东西是没用的,就不要使用的了
另外一个,信息都后去并不是那么重要
行动很重要
你掌握那么多信息,没有信动
一切都是零